boa tarde a todos
é um prazer estar aqui se você está em
comida a mais em casa o que fazem com
essa comida confessa sobrou muita comida
do jantar boa veada colocaram o vosso
espírito culinário os melhores
ingredientes a melhor tecnologia que tem
na cozinha mas produzem tão bem cozinha
um bairro que sobrou muita o que vocês
fazem congelo guarda 13 dias seguintes
nós vivemos uma crise onde não há falta
é absolutamente nenhuma de dinheiro a
chez de dinheiro
as crises anteriores a moto produção
capitão espera os críticos deram gritos
de esquecer do período medieval da
equipe talvez não tenha sido um
extraordinário salto faz aos modos de
produção anterior porque ao criar
mercados nacionais e internacionais
ao libertar os homens do sistema feudal
dez passagens aos senhores é de 60 dos
tributos aos senhores é permitiu a pouco
um desenvolvimento extraordinário 10
forças produtivas e com onde uma
situação extraordinária ou seja nós
deixamos de estar à mercê de pragas
agrícolas de formas que eram
devastadoras para as comunidades nós
passamos a ter domínio um grande domínio
sobre a natureza um enorme domínio sobre
a natureza e portanto uma praga uma
forma já não tem o efeito devastador
porque porque nós pensarmos justamente
desenvolvemos a técnica desenvolvemos a
ciência desenvolvemos tudo através do
trabalho para proporcionar a esses
museus mas esse modelo está no seu
domínio histórico com tudo
é com todos os modelos são histórias que
está em princípio meio e fim
nós vivemos hoje seguramente um processo
de decadência do modo de produção em que
sistematicamente
estamos a assistir à destruição de
capitais para garantir a sua valorização
ou sarja produziu-se imensa comida nós
nunca produzimos tanto como no século 21
nunca produzimos tantas máquinas tanta
gente com capacidade de trabalhar em
inventar e temos tanta comida a mais mas
alguém algumas poucas pessoas se viram
que para nós garantimos que aquela maçã
com isso sozinha
a única maneira de ela ser valorizada é
destruir tudo o resto está à volta é a
única maneira de salvar as taxas de
lucro é garantir a destruição recessiva
nós vamos chamar destruição criadora que
é completamente assim todos num país com
25% força de trabalho desempregada e 3
milhões de pobres oficialmente estar a
chamar criativo ao facto cimo de sabotar
a produção disparar as máquinas para não
produzirem description zico caras que
estão a trabalhar no dobro a quer das
tarefas que era do tempo de trabalho
mandando integrar as pessoas obviamente
investiu se dá nos filhos a e ver seus
netos que chega o skype é é um processo
de fusão da nossa força de trabalho
qualificada e não nós precisamos das
pessoas a trabalhar nós precisamos de
produzir estamos a perder estudo para
garantir a salvar a acionistas privados
que normalmente aparecem sobre a
ideologia de algo que parece sempre como
como como eterno e como inquestionável
não é como se tivesse fundamentação
científica
são os chamados mercados
a austrália é uma ideologia uma
violência política mas é uma ideologia
eu pessoalmente acho que é uma cirurgia
com os determinado com qualquer outro
jet com qualquer outra cirurgia ou seja
a um grupo
pessoas que defendem que efetivamente se
deve colocar as pessoas a trabalhar até
à exaustão se deve ter um milhão e mais
desempregados e do desemprego por si o
nosso salário de todos para baixo se
deve não ter financiar o estado social
ea segurança social o nosso de financiar
a educação não se deve ter transporte
coletivo de qualidade para garantir a
remuneração das feministas privados em
um dia o que não podem ser apresentada
como uma verdade absoluta é uma
ideologia hoje time é como você chava em
é fortemente defendida pelo sindicato
internacional de banqueiros que é uma
organização que não está oficialmente
criada mas quis mas que tem dominado as
nossas é é as nossas previsões
todos os dias nós temos o sindicato
internacional dos bancários às oito da
noite a explicar os que vivemos acima
das nossas possibilidades
apesar do mundo hoje ter 62 pessoas
segundo a ok se falou em suspeita ong de
combate á fome no mundo e ajuda
solidária 62 pessoas que está em riqueza
equivalente à metade da humanidade é
esse o valor último do relatório deste
ano da fox samu
eu sou historiador e quer chá de tempo
do tempo presente e do tempo futuro o
tempo futuro é o da história
o tempo que nós vivemos é o da pré
história porque vai joão quando nós
vivemos num mundo em que um grupo seleto
dos senhores investem ogivas nucleares
tanques de guerra farmácias que não
curam e apresenta toda esta imensa
panóplia como investimentos competitivos
nós temos que admitir indiretamente que
vivemos num estado barbarense social e
de pré história e eu criei hoje
falaremos aqui da história do futuro
a cirurgia só o projeto tem não está
morto
nós como seres humanos distinguimos dos
animais desde logo o movimento é a
capacidade através do trabalho
transformar a natureza dominaria
mesa de preferência de forma sustentável
obviamente mas quer dizer extraordinário
em espécie humana é a única espécie
conquistou todos os passos da terra não
é todos os cinco continentes zonas mais
difíceis dos desertos as altas montanhas
por uma extraordinária capacidade
científica de invenção de criação ou
seja nós temos já estava irado
extraordinária de prévia edição nós
temos ideias e construímos idéias e
pensamos e executá-los
são projeções do futuro todos nós temos
cirurgia e que não está em está morto
o problema é quando nós achamos que é a
nossa ideologia é ideologia é de toda a
sociedade e apresentarmos como e
biologia e geologia nacional entende que
vai assinar fobia o nacionalismo ou
outro tipo de ideologias como e biologia
da austeridade eo caps falar hoje do
teria o dia que é uma ideologia de
abundância e e vibrado muito mal tratado
ao longo do século 20 chamada socialismo
teve um giro socialismo na sobretudo
sobre seguinte associada obviamente ao
nascimento do movimento operário da
transformação das sociedades agrícolas
para as sociedades organizadas
justamente da transformação de uma de
uma economia é muito pouco desenvolvida
para uma economia é altamente cada vez
mais produtiva e da idéia de que nós
poderíamos finalmente o final alguns
modos de produção viver numa sociedade
onde as diferenças e o indivíduo
ganhasse um espaço inédito porque as
diferenças de classe social e de origem
eram iluminadas
claro que esteja aí foi brutalmente
tratada pelas ditaduras como a ditadura
stalinista cotidiana da china mal isto é
ela também é hoje uma ideia muito
maltratada pelos partidos sociais
democratas e socialistas eu penso que a
maioria dos partidos do mundo ainda tem
a palavra social e sim social o
democrata
seus nomes que é hoje em dia associado
ao assistencialismo e portanto as
pessoas não devem ter direito ao
trabalho e viver do trabalho elas devem
ter é é possibilidade de estender
permanentemente mau estado e requerer
uma cantina social a os livros
financiados uma taxa moderadora para
poder entrar no hospital portanto é a
substituição de direitos pela
arbitrariedade total da assistência que
é obviamente digna porque o século 21
o trabalho é um bem social deve ser
dividido por todos reduz a jornada de
trabalho sem redução salarial e é isso
que nos permite criar pensar em ninguém
ver deve ver do assistencialismo e
portanto o socialismo tem sido assim
imensamente mal tratado como idéia mas a
idéia é obviamente luiza daí que está
associada a ela ea beleza da proteção do
indivíduo a ideia de que a recuperação
nos permite trabalhar mais e melhor é em
vez da competição é idéia de que é essa
cooperação permita bunda ânsia e
abundância prime com essa satisfação das
necessidades básicas
respeitando com tal é as diferenças e
aumentar do imenso a nossa capacidade de
inventar criar de ciência certa porque
colocamos o trabalho que precisamos é em
vez de trabalhar para viver e viver para
trabalhar passarmos é trabalhar e é para
viver
claro que vocês devem dizer acredito que
digam que esta pressa uma idéia hoje
estranha parece uma idéia hoje
absolutamente impensável o éter perigosa
acreditar em deus é uma idéia mais
estranha vampiros invasões
extraterrestres e derrube os
apocalípticos
é uma ideia mais estranha então alguma
coisa
estranha se passa quando nós achamos que
o pressão para a produção entre nós é
algo impossível de alcançar
mas é caminharmos todos os dias o
obscurantismo de pensamento medieval
acreditando em imensa as coisas que não
está em qualquer fundamento científico
o convencermos a nós de que o tempo
presente é um tempo a histórico é um
tempo a história é um tempo mesmo viveu
é um tempo em que não há alternativa é
um tempo em que não há disputa vir a
existir projectos políticos a realidade
ela é como é e nós não podemos mudar
apesar do mundo todos os dias e estar a
mudar a nossa volta nós estamos aqui
neste auditório operado e terra continua
a mover e nós nos sentimos que a terra
estava ver portanto o mundo não pára lá
fora se em 50 anos no século 19 nós
reduzimos a jornada de trabalho de 16
para oito horas porque é que 100 anos do
século 20 no rio dos índios de oito para
quatro anos
eu acho que é possível viver numa
sociedade um da transportes coletivos a
toda hora eu já ouvi parte do tempo
acionada censurado a holandesa vão dizer
é plano bicicleta o que está em um
transporte coletivo três em três minutos
comboio autocarro pra lá e de bicicleta
todos os holandeses utilizam o combóio
oca claques implica financiar o
transporte coletivos em vez de financiar
em sanções fiscais às empresas do
transporte individual
são escolhas atenção são projetos
políticos de toda a gente tem
legitimidade defendeu seus projetos
políticos
eu defendo uma sociedade onde se
privilegia o transporte coletivo para
libertar as tiradas dos carros para que
as pessoas acordem manhã e primeira
notícia que tenho não seja do trânsito
saí gbps de teatro seja do novo grupo
jazz como nós ouvimos aqui 12 em uma
sociedade que discutir
é não se as crianças vão ter exames
imaginem vocês que são tão pobre no
século 21 nós não estamos a discutir se
as crianças têm acesso a tocar um
instrumento musical
se as crianças não podem estar durante a
tarde a brincar nos seus bairros
revistados fechadas nas escolas que se
transformaram em armas às 11 horas por
dia 10 horas por dia 12 horas por dia do
chefe da manhã a chefe da tarde as
nossas crianças estão aí com problemas
gravíssimos de obesidade hiperatividade
fechadas nós chegamos ao século 21 temos
as nossas crianças encerradas há espaço
me concentracionário onde não sabe o que
é brincar
vejam bem nós acabamos com o trabalho
infantil mas temos as crianças 8 9 10 11
horas tenham horários uma dupla na
escola com com seis sete oito anos
ou nós temos professores chilenos
quem vai para o professor adora crianças
se a primeira razão tem que durar o que
vai fazer
a segunda razão é que eu é significa
mente impecável eu não tenho uns três
anos e num semestre que virou um
trimestre porque nós precisamos
apresentar na união européia resultados
extraordinários licenciados muito
rapidamente
eu tirei um curso com calma muito bem
tirar eu sábado muito porque os há muito
e porque ela adora crianças e eu tenho
que ser muito acarinhado tem que ser bem
pago e não pode estar entupido em
trabalho burocrático ccedil otilde es
hoje é no setor administrativo o
burocrata e da escola
então nós temos uma coisa extraordinária
nós não temos uma empresa que nós
vendemos em seis meses atalho mas nós
aqui há 30 anos vamos ter
extraordinários profissionais que
tiveram as melhores escolas do mundo as
nossas e aprender um imenso e adoram o
fazem estão disponíveis então para nos
dar nos próximos 40 e 50 anos quando
tiverem 30 o que de melhor nós nos vemos
durante 30 anos e dá lhes a melhor
educação que nós podíamos dar nós vamos
entrar num hospital e não vai misturar
com a palavra dinheiro e entrou dentro
do hospital é saúde não é
não se compra e não se vende é
absolutamente intolerável que o que é um
bem essencial dessa vida entre sequer a
palavra mercantilização dinheiro ou
troca é saúde é uma prestação de serviço
ninguém pode ter medo de ficar doente
porque tem medo não tem dinheiro para
pagar para se curar
vamos ter uma noção de cultura nesta
sociedade ainda é em que nós consumimos
cultura mas produzimos cultura
todos nós vamos ter aprendido e por isso
até sabemos apreciar melhor o que é um
bom mau que atua
todos nós aprendemos um instrumento
musical e por isso reconhecemos outra
linguagem é música nem todos os jogos na
pianistas nesta nova sociedade como é
óbvio mas todos nós vamos compreender a
linguagem musical e portanto não vai
haver uma expressão entre consumo e
produção cultural vai haver uma
unificação entre produção e consumo
cultural produtores e consumidores ao
mesmo tempo homens completos como se o
senhor há tanto tempo
vejo que nós vivemos num mundo onde a
maior indústria cultural do mundo ao
miúdo 90% os filmes são sobre invasões
desses restos de units e guerras
tomás marina e san simón inventaram com
muito menos recursos o amor eterno e o
falante estéreo ou eo e inventores tupia
primeiramente o horror e observarem para
nos convencer ajustamento que quem tenta
mudar vai ficar pior
vamos ter universidades que são
universidades ou saio lugares saber
universal significa que as portas das
nossas universidades nessa sociedade vão
estar abertas a toda a agenda ao
trabalho manual ao matemático ao
cientista ao professor
a doméstica as nossas chapas estão
abertas para as pessoas entrarem ouvirem
o conhecimento não há mal nenhum pelo
contrário
temos acesso ao conhecimento quanto nós
vamos ser todos muito diferente de ter
cuidado sempre diferente
aliás devemos ter habilidades novas
conhecer vimos que existia porque já não
vai estar atado sair pedra uma estrutura
da sobrevivência dos trabalhos que são
um é e suportáveis uma vez que as
pessoas se eternizam nos trabalhos que o
daia e para os quais o movimento estão a
ser semi torturados do ponto de vista da
psicologia do amor algumas elaborar os
horários de trabalho e até porque
dependem deus para sobreviver nós temos
que produzir temos produzirem todos
temos que trabalhar e chefe naturalmente
as crianças os idosos as pessoas com
algum tipo de deficiência que têm que
ser ajudadas e vai impor todos nós não é
ajudados com valores miseráveis mas não
há nenhuma razão para que as
universidades para que toda a gente não
vai nas universidades e pelas nossas
universidades pagas pelos impostos de
todos nós não saibam gratuitas
beneficiais e do porta aberta o que cada
um depois fará com que aprendeu é está
em aberto nós não podemos pôr em fechar
a porta a ninguém ao conhecimento como
nós sabemos está produzido em cima de
ombros de gigantes que nos precederam e
que nós fomos ver com tanto cuidado e
atenção
eu queria
esperamos vocês com um poema que agora
de um livro que não fizeram agora aqui
na terra ex deste convite maravilhoso
que me fizeram um poema naturalmente do
antônio judicial
o certo é que reunirá vial difere
bastante da realidade pensada
os homens não esperam mesmo nada eu
expert no e isso é todo mal
nós não somos aquilo que fazemos nós pra
nós somos aquilo que fazemos mas
sobretudo somos aquilo que fazer
para mudar aquilo que somos nós somos a
nossa imensa capacidade de projeção e
transformação do futuro
não procuramos viver na pré história
como vivemos hoje é que todos os dias
chegam cadáver ao mar um de câmbio
isso para nós é essa história nós
queremos entrar na história e lembraram
por isso do deputado
você estava em um momento quente como eu
a sorte de ter a voz deliciosa tomar
conta e vimos essas sociedades agrárias
uma das avós faziam um trabalho
essencialmente doméstico agrícola eu
tivesse sorte e uma das minhas duas
maravilhosas a voz era a entrada e ela
disse sim quando evitava-se de mirar
mais salgadas que é uma coisa que vocês
são umas palmadas mas caetés chama nuno
salgado e outro dia entrei num
restaurante em lisboa que pintou na sua
presa
se o destino de virar as costas se o
destino se o distinto e virar as costas
a pau pedras altas
obrigada pela vossa adesão